Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to "The Last Look DEMO"
Now this is a game that is going to be coming out later this year
That's supposed to be very scary and what-not
But this is a demo, so it's just gonna show
like, um a
Things that demos show? I don't need to explain to you what a demo is, do I? (maybe)
So lets get into the game why don't we?
and also, I loaded up the game to test out some things and I saw this girl, and I didn't realize it at first
but she's standing next to her own portrait wearing her EXACT same clothes, like how narcissistic do you have to be?
(deep, scary voice) You wouldn't..
Anyway
mmmmmm
hm
Albeit?
(Mark makes confused looks)
What the fuck is Magairi-
Oh
Does it now?
I don't know
Oh veeerrry funny...
I-I can't understand anything
Why do these horror games ALWAYS throw EVERYTHING at you
JUST to confuse you?
Were you listening to that dialogue because HOLYSHIT
I can't believe how many open ended sen- like questions they said!
(Mark mocking the people talking before) "Oh I *can't* believe *that* thing"
"Lets talk about 'Magaria'"
"Noo you *can't* go in *that* place!"
"Oh GOD this girl's the SIXTH one!"
(Mark takes a deep breath)
WHAT THE FUCK ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?!
Sorry.. Anyway, thats just a pet (named Steve) peeve of mine
Wh-when THINGS THROW YOU in like its totally understandable
that you don't have all the pieces together but COME ON
Be a little- (Mark giggles) Be a little easy on me I don-
I- My brain *very* stupid
I can't handle this
Okay Anyway
So
"Tired"
"The she plays noise too!"
"Its okay!"
"Listen!"
"How much stop time has passed?"
"No"
I can't read this
Give me the goddamn light
"Without you I'm nothing" and numbers..
"Both.. dire"
From 3 to 6..
Is there a clue here?
There's a lot of really little writing in there, but I can't really read it
With all this light flickering over here
Oh
"Don't run it wi-" Woah
"D-don't run it will.." What does that say?
"Don't run it'll TAKE YOU??"
"Drink..."
Oh there's like some night blindness.. "Drink it will restore your.."
"Strength??"
"Hide, listen to the bells!" Okay.. Listen to
Ooo
oh
"I want... to play" Who wants to play?
okay.. hello
Hi..
Oh. Oh, Hi
Hellooo
Ee dat mi?
Dat MII?
Alice Johnson?
Uh huh
Luckily.. huh?
"THhhHE BITCH"
Okay, so what does that mean?
Okay.. so how did you get here..?
and..
u-uhGh Okay
wait whats this
Well you never know.. it could help
And are those my boobs?
(Way to ask the questions everyone else is asking, Mark)
Wow-huh
What a wonderful first person s-perpepective this is!
yes
okay..
Okay so.. so what do we do about it?
OhhH Like a bobby pin, in the girl-y stuff!
(Mark's bobby pin dream is crushed)
Oh COME ON
Thats so- Thats so obviously the thing just get it
(quietly) ah damn it.
new
okay..
Well, reach your hand in there!
Well, probably is
okay, so anything about these words and the bathtub?
I couldn't even tell that it was blood..
Dip-dip Take- Take a dive!
Ohh yeah
That's good.
Yep yep.
Yeah
(Mark gasps) fffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffff
uuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
ckkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkkk
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFF
WITH YOU
Wooah
Alright-y then
Well I'm coated in
'Something??'
Oh
Did
D-Did you?
WHILE you were being drowned
WELL that's perfectly normal
Time to
'Rationalize'
The situation
MAN it's awesome to have BOOBS
I-I know I don't want to put to much emphasis on this
But
MAN I've always said If I had boobs I would never get anything done because I would be too
busy playing with them  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
anyway..
Okay, so I got that opened
I still don't..
Okay?
Where would that be? (Good question..)
Is that my portrait AGAIN?
EEE DAT MI?
Shuuuurrre
yeah..
I dunno
Maybe its your.. Alter ego?
SMASH IT THEN, DUUUUH
Oh.
Well alright
(Mockingly) I HOPE NO ONE HEARD THAT
Okay, sure, alright then.
wowthisisdark
COME ON, BE BRAVE! I'D DO IT!
LISTEN TO WHAT YOUR *HEART* SAYS
Heart says run away fastly? Okay
alright then
So I need to find a flashlight or SOMETHING, or else I'm not going to go anywhere..
hello
hhhEYY Come on, you're dirty tricks won't work on me
"I destroy myself day after day." "I hate you, Leave me"
Okay
aH
(Deep breath in)
Astrophysics? What does astrophysics  have to do with the horrifying mansion that's haunted and stuff?
oooh. Hii
I'll be with you in a second.
Ain't that fascinating..
I think you're about to talk now
Hello?
This looks *warm* and *inviting*
you hear that?
(mark realizes he made a terrible mistake)
EEeeeuuugh
Eeeeuuugh
okay
okay..
Okay
Well, I don't know?
I don't even know krugey
Man, how am I going to know krugey and be able to do this?
(Mark imitates the beeping sound) Boodododo-lo
okay
UUuuum
could just try '1111'..
Lets see..
(Mark begins reading off the page.)
Okay..
Well, thats just as confusing as ever but at least it..
got somethin else..
Ooo, how about "2013?"
There's a lot of numbers here
Uh huh
okay
AHH, '0706' IN BOLD, you wonder if thats it. Kathryn's birthday.
'0706' okay
I got it
Oh seven Oh six..
Ba-da bing bing!
okay.
'connection could not be established' :(
'My pictures'..
'connection could not be established' (Not again :<)
2 unread mails..
(Mark hiccups)
(Mark begins reading the email.)
SHIT.
(Mocking) BlOodY HelL
okay so what about..
(Mark begins reading the email on screen)
(Mark smacks his lips like in an ASMR video)
These are some WEIRD times that you're putting up here..
(Mark continues reading the email.)
That email didn't make any goddamn sense AT ALL
Okay then..
(lip smack)
Ooo
Oh
wait
Ooop
pOp
'Serious Attention Whoring'
'privacy is overrated'
wha's that..
Wha
What is
What is happening?
I can't
Why can't I mouse into here?
That doesn't make any  goddamn sense, I can't mouse in there
Weeeird..
Oookay..
I guess I'm done then..
'cause I can't send any emails..
Ooo It's so dark..
Can I get a flashlight?
Pleeeeease
Oh
Woah
Hello
(Mark begins reading the side of the page (The black))
(mark gasps.)
Oookee-dokee then.
that's weird..
Well then... hhh..
Wha-What else am I here for?
Oh!
Ah Hah!
Well, I dunno
Something went very wrong.. 'I'm sorry Kathy'?
AH
COOL
ALL I HAD TO DO WAS TURN ON THE LIGHT
MMMMMMMMMMMMMMM
I think Kathy's his daughter
'frIckEn dOUCHHE'
Okay
(Mark gasps sharply)
whAT HAppened
wHO'S OUt there
Someone over here?
HUH?
Ah, thats some excuse for you.. GROW SOme..
Baallls? I dunno..
huh
Aaaahhh, okay
So
Hang on
What was wrong, I didn't even do anything
Ah?
Okay.
Alright
So
I-I know what this is
This is in relation to that weird email about the dog
So if I look at the dog again, It's gonna tell me times!
That's why it didn't make any sense!
12 o' clock
Oooohhh
The dogs name is Safety
AhhHH, Okay
so
Then walk a- OOOOHHH
Walk him one full around at 12, when you're back it should be 2 o' clock!
oOOohh
Ookay
Twelve, two, four, six, four.
okay
Twelve..
Two..
oh shit
okay
AHHH WHAT IS THAT
WHAT THE FUCK IS HAPPENING
OOOOOOOOOOOOOO
aHHHHH
UHO
What the fUCK WAS THAT?
YOU WANNA TELL ME??
WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAT??
HHOOLY SHIT
UHG
That might've been a bug or something, but it was unintentionally the CREEPIEST THING I'VE EVER SEEN
Oh man..
Fuck, okay
Oh yeah, One big round
That's right
Twelllve
Two..
Four..
Six..
aaaHHHHHHHH
Okay
Sounds like I unlocked it INDEED
'Emergency Generator, handle with care'
How 'bout I punch it as hard as I can?
While waiting for the weird hair to float around my face..
(Female voice) "Safety emergency generator: ONLINE"
That's convenient.. What did that do for me?
Did it turn the lights on?
It didn't over here..
But maybe it did on the other side
Or maybe it did something else in the office there and I'm just running away from where I actually need to go
Which would be totally stupid and dumb and I shouldn't have done that. I bet there's nothing oVER HERE
YEP, THERE'S NOT. I MADE A BIG GOOFY ERROR
'CAUSE I'M A BIG DUMB DOOFY-DOO
oh boy, look at me wanderin' the walls..
Wasting everybody's time...
I'm sorry..
Oh!
Hello
What are you?
Ahh
AAhhh
Maybe you could take it..
EhhH
So if I take it out of there, I can put it in there
(Mark inhales sharply)
DAMN
DAMN DAMN DAMN (Daniel)
Oooo?
AAhhh?
yyyyyyyyyyyyyyyAAY-
I-
w-wHAT DO I DO?!
WHERE? I DUNNO WHERE TO HIDE!?
'HIDE BEHIND THE COUCH'
HOW DO I GET- UUUUUHHHGHHHHHH
aaAAHH
(Slither-y, goop-yish noises.)
(CROSS YOUR FINGERS FOR MARK, GUYS!)
(Slight static as the noises continue)
(Banging on the door)
Okay...
(Banging continues, and worsens)
UAH
(The noises continue, with less banging)
WHATDOIDO
WHATDOIDO??
AM I IN COntrol or something here??
(Sinister Music, along with the noises from before.)
(The music grows louder, and the noises are gone.)
(Mark urgently whispering) Probably not dON't LOok
(Loud music/noise)
Oh
Oh.
Okay.
(Children playing/yelling in the background)
(A little girl says 'daddy'. The noises from the children continue.)
Okay, Woah I'm actually in this I thought this was just a cutscene
hOOLY CRAP I can't see much of anything
Uugh This is disorienting and sickening
DO you?
Okay?
Then do it (JUSTDOIT)
Stop bein' such a doof, and just walk forward..
Okay..
Uggghh, Man, I'm about to vomit..
UuHGHHHH
(Slightly coughs while also slightly laughs)
Back into the realms of the epileptic *squid* on *acid*
UggHH gOD
'Fall'? AWWWW, THATS THE END?
MAAaann...
I wanted to get SCARED by the MONSTER :(
Alright, hang on.
I have an idea.. (Oh no)
Lemme see where it drops me in the continue..
Okay, so we're about to open the panel.. I got the key, I got the, uh, clock all done. I did the safety thing
I pushed that.. I believe I pushed that, right? Just a BA-DOINKIE-DOINK
Okay, is that Ba-Doinkie-doinked?
Yeah, That's been Ba-Doinkie-Doinked.
So I can open this because the key apparently opens this panel and we're gonnA DO THIS THING
(Mark takes a deep breath)
HA-BOINK
I-
I said-
Ha-
(Oh no, Mark is about to explode..)
HA-BOINK
HA-BOINK!
and then.. We make the monster come by and WE'RE NOT GOING TO HIDE THIS TIME
Because we don't want to run away, *we want to be brave*
aHHuH
oHNO
OH GOD
Okay
Uh oh..
Maybe I won't do that
Maybe I won't
BRING IT ON!
(Mark summons his wILL POWER)
I GOT MY SHIELDS UP
FUCK YOUUUUU
(Monster screams, and loud bangs on the door)
AH, Oh god
Hi
We-
Well alright then!
That was it??!
You're gonna put some crackling in my ears then have some guy in a robe SPRINT at me?
That was it??
hopin' for more then that..
AWWW, thats the end. Oh well..
Thats all we got for now, so that is the end of the demo
Thank you everybody so much for watching,
I will *probably* play this when the full one comes out
And obviously, you know, I ragged on them for not giving me any information
But it's just a demo, they just want to get people intrigued on it
(Mark takes a deep breath)
But it's just frustrating nOT TO KNOW
(He then sighs.)
But either way we'll get to the mystery in a little bit so
(Breaths in sharply)
THANK YOU Everybody so much for watching
(Another ASMR worthy lip-smack)
Check out the other scary games I've played down in the description below, or in the annotations over there and thanks again
And as always I will see you in the next video
BUH-BYE!